is it true that Jennifer helped you with
some of the passions to understand the
Fashions of that era yeah you know I
mean the
it's brilliant and helps me in every
conceivable way
JLo stunned and Antonio Grimaldi cozing
up to her man on and off the carpet as
for Buddy Matt's look in the film he had
to transform into Nike basketball Guru
and exec Sonny Vaccaro I wanted to put
Matt in a bodysuit put some weight on
him and we shot him with the lens that
expanded his face a little bit you know
I so accustomed to seeing Matt Damon as
the kind of Jason Bourne can't lose
gonna win no matter what and I wanted to
try to create more of that sort of
Underdog feeling you know air out April
5th tells the true story of Nike's
pursuit of Michael Jordan Ben plays
company co-founder Phil Knight you got a
name for it Air Jordan
maybe it'll grow on me tell me about the
wig and the tights that was the gear
that was hot in 84 that was the that was
how you did it that's a good look it's
back you don't know that I don't know I
don't know my kids my son rocks like all
the time like that he showed up in the
whole crew just was like
a shoe is just a shoe
and is that Oscar buzz we're hearing for
Viola Davis and real-life husband Julius
tennen who play Jordan's parents let the
campaign begin tonight
of the Oscars were you in that bear
costume not me that was definitely not
me I was home in New York he was the
bear he was the cocaine bear he did he
say he wasn't the bird are you ever
gonna kiss and make up with Kimmel no no
he's
why would I ever do that hey I'd love to
take a picture with you but we ran out
of time
all right
and the night was also full of nostalgia
it's been 25 years since Matt and Ben
teamed up in their oscar-winning movie
Good Will Hunting meanwhile Matt and Ben
have another movie coming your way
Unstoppable obviously uh a very his very
famous spouse got a great role in it
this is actually where we premiered
Goodwill Hunting like right here yeah
that theater I'm nervous I'm really
nervous now I have my kids with me it's
just crazy it's just nuts man it's what
a life
[Music]
thank you